uh what's your view on what should
happen with the US with the Supreme
Court here in the UK
well we don't want another Independence
referendum right now uh I think your
correspondent said a few minutes ago
Scotland's quite divided if you're a
nationalist you probably want uh another
referendum if you're not you don't
um the country's been through two of
these in the last decade one in Scotland
and then the brexit referendum and we're
now in a situation where we've got a
major cost of living crisis a major
energy price crisis uh you know if I was
living in Scotland now I don't anymore
the issue that I'd been more struck by
this week would have been the discussion
among senior NHS managers to introduce
charging in a two-tier service to
undermine the whole concept of the NHS
so there's plenty of issues for the
Scottish government to focus on rather
than this never-ending constitutional
wrangling do you think that people who
can afford it should pay to go and see
the doctor no I think that would
undermine the basic principle of the NHS
it's there to be free at the point of
use for people of all incomes and all
backgrounds and I don't want to see it
fractured in that way what do you think
about the Prime Minister allegedly
paying 250 quid to see the doctor so
it's his money it's up to him it is I
don't you that choice to to use private
Health Care is always available to
people and I don't criticize anyone for
making that choice it's not just about
someone like the Prime Minister who's
quite a wealthy man there are some
people who don't have a lot of money who
find out because of the waiting lists uh
that they are being forced to use their
life savings or making a decision to do
that because of Weights sometimes of
years so I don't criticize anyone for
making that choice but my focus is to
make the NHS so good that people don't
feel pressured into making that choice
and that's what happened the last time
labor was in government use of Private
health care declined because we managed
to get the waiting list down we managed
to get the waiting times down and the
service was at such a high level of
satisfaction that people didn't feel
pressured into making that kind of
choice it wasn't ideal situation with it
it was an awful lot better than it is
well so just to clarify labor supports
the Prime Minister using Private health
care if he wants to it's his free choice
to do so my focus as I said is on making
the NHS so good that people don't feel
they have to make that choice and do you
think that people from overseas should
be allowed to come into the UK to fill
the jobs vacancies that are presently in
place in the NHS they'll always be a
need for people to come here and work
hard my own parents did this and I want
to thank everybody who's come from
overseas to work hard to make a new life
here but at the same time as that always
been part of our labor market so of
course right we do everything we can to
train and equip our own workers to try
to get some of the hundreds of thousands
of people who've left the labor market
since covid back into work both of these
things are going to be necessary if
we're going to be able to fill the
vacancies we've got so does that mean
because we of course heard didn't we
from your leader yesterday at the CBI
was what he was saying meaning that
immigration will go up or down he was
asked us yesterday I think and he said
it's not a matter of putting a Target on
it's the system that you have and the
system you have will be informed by your
labor market needs so you know we don't
want to see sectors uh just collapse
them because they can't have staff we've
got the migration advisory committee we
want to give that a beefed up role right
across government constantly reviewing
this but where immigration takes place
where people come here be on a different
basis to the Past because we're now
outside the European Union but both uh
you know Talent from overseas energy
from overseas and hard work from
overseas both are on training and
equipping our own workers will be part
of the labor market in the future and
how would you make that happen well
we've got a points-based system uh
people will apply but how does a point
space system work for a cleaning lady or
a cleaning gentleman from Romania well
someone from Romania or anywhere else
will apply for the right to come and
work here and we've got this body the
migration advisory committee they look
at the sectors they look at the
shortages you've got agricultural
workers as well for example where there
are particular pressures so you do this
on the basis of advice uh for uh for
your economy but it's really important
that the UK remains open to talented
hard-working people from around the
world and we will so labor accepts that
we have got an aging population more
people are over 65 than under 16 and we
need more people to come in to help
support our society we're always going
to need some I don't want to put a
figure on it but at the same time no I
keep pushing you won't give me one yeah
and I won't because at the same time
we've got to train and equip our own
workers we've got to make sure for
example we've got a policy for a
breakfast club for every primary school
and you might say what's that got to do
with this if we had that it would mean
that more young parents could get to
work and wouldn't have to make that
difficult choice about when they can
drop the children off and so on we've
got half a million people they're more
mostly older who've left the labor
market since covid can we do more to
give them the help and support needed to
get back into work I think we can and
that makes sense to do too okay when you
say Elder I prefer the term more
experienced but there we go um talk to
me about the rail strikes are we
supporting them this time around or not
we don't want to see these strikes
because they'll cause huge inconvenience
to the public this has been going on for
what six months now and I think the
government's got to engage because with
real strikes around the country with
people not being able to get a GP
appointment there are all these services
that aren't working as they should and
it just feeds into this sense that
Britain isn't operating properly and the
government can't stand back and just
watch that so was that a yes or a no to
supporting rail strikes it's not a
matter of important strikes I never want
to see strikes happen so you don't
support these things I understand why
people want a periods these things
should be Revol resolved run the
negotiating table with the union and the
employers that's what's going to happen
in the end so if it happens sooner
that's much better than more
inconvenience over Christmas and the new
year yeah but if these people go on
strike the rail workers go on strike
then it's going to impact on shops of
course policy that's why I don't want to
see the strikes I want to see an added
impetus to negotiation Minister's not
standing back let's try and get a
settlement for this because it's a
dispute that's been going on for about
six months now I suppose your colleagues
actually both your colleagues earlier on
this week Monday and Tuesday when they
were sat exactly where you were and I
was asking them whether they supported
David Beckham and his support for the
Qatar regime during the World Cup what
do you think
I think there's too much of a sense of
control from FIFA and Qatar in this
world cup I'm looking at all this
policing of what uh Team captains can
wear on their armbands what it can see
on your shot even the hearts people can
wear I think they need to be a bit more
relaxed let people enjoy the football
this doesn't feel so far like a happy
world cup and I want to see a happy
world yeah but what about one of our
national heroes being an ambassador for
that sort of behavior well that's his
decision
um but I I think that the atmosphere
around this world cup has not been the
joyful Festival of football that fans
like me have always enjoyed when we've
watched the World Cup in the past uh and
you know that's a shame and I just hope
that the uh you know the football
authorities learn from some of the
experiences over the last few years are
you supporting England or Wales I'm
supporting England and Wales and the
British teams to do as well as possible
okay who do you want to win
uh you know I'd love one of the British
teams to win the World Cup you're such a
politician uh if that can't happen do
not hardly watched any of it so far
really did you see Argentina I didn't
see Argentina oh I saw the result yeah
but I've hardly watched the kick so far
because I've been so busy in Parliament
so maybe at the weekend I'll actually
get to watch it well you should see the
England game on um on sky or something
I'm not sure if we're able to rerun it
but certainly you can see some of the
clips six two
a very good result a great start exactly
that it's good to see you as always
thank you very much